all right little update all right in
regards to the pj washington brittany
renner if you aren't familiar pj
washington is the nba rookie who got
involved with a woman who was
substantially older an instagram thought
and uh after she got pregnant she
basically dumped them so let's find out
what happened what happened i don't know
who needs to hear this
but stand your ground
it's sacred so when you stand your
ground
you stand in your truth
when you stand in your truth
you stand in your power and when you say
in your power
come to a place where i've just accepted
that my light is so bright that it
causes all the roaches to scatter in
places they thought they could hide
it's just me being me
it just causes such an uproar
like loving yourself is such a
rebellious act these days you know
but i'm here to tell you i am so
not sorry
why would she be though
but what what but hold on but what was
she what are we doing this is not an
update
that's not an update she planned the
thing all day long she said it from the
beginning that's not update that's not
an update it's like if i'm saying
abba
i'm going to new york city
update
i'm in new york city
i was planning to go there the whole
time of course i'm in new york city
that's what i'm doing
she said where she was going in the
videos and [ __ ] that's why
now now
update she's there yeah
something else
update i mean yeah it is an update
because you know you're not there you're
you're in new york now but i mean update
something different you know some update
that we want oh snap you had an accident
on your way to new york city where you
at now
catskill
you're on the tap nz bridge
you didn't reach new york yet
okay
but this was expected you said you
called it you called it you were playing
pool
you playing pool you had the cue ball
you said yo
eight corner
left
update i won the [ __ ] game
that's what happened
she aligned the the white ball
with the a ball
she said top corner left
update she won the game
happy
she called it bruh
i mean the update would be like i'm
gonna give the money back i'm willing to
work with it i'd be like god damn that's
an update that's not the thought i
thought she was god damn
the thought i thought she was yeah i
said that right that's not a thought i
thought she was she really oh that's the
update but this
that's not an update this is a
confirmation she's catholic confirmation
a big thank you to today's sponsor npl
mobile premier league i see this a lot
nowadays but people love to play games
on their phones when they're on the way
to work when they're coming back from
school when they're just waiting for
people so what mpl offers is a great way
for you to play games on your phone
while you also making money yes let me
repeat
you can make money
while you play games so the many games
that you can play from solitaire to
eight ball blast to baseball and much
much more personally even though i've
never played in real life i like playing
baseball on the app see how you like
that home run
easy peasy about to get this moolah and
the best part is that getting the money
is very easy and reliable whether it be
through paypal or through bank transfers
the process is not only reliable but
it's extremely safe so what are you
waiting for you're already playing the
games might as well make some money so
check out the link in the description
below if you
stand your downl standing your truth you
know with all
the little hallmark quotes good for
instagram captions she is who we thought
she was
thought she was
yes sir from all the other previous
videos that we saw it's more of the same
so
what did i gather from this
if you guys expect that i'm gonna have
any sympathy for any man who gets
fleeced by her in the future you are
[ __ ] crazy oh it's just gonna keep on
going hey man with this much evidence of
how she is and who she is on the
internet and you still [ __ ] with her
and you get played [ __ ] you a new fool
and you deserve it all right isn't it
what shame me once full [ __ ] fool me
once shame on me she shame me once shake
me twice [ __ ] shane just shake shame
back in your arms that's where i want to
be
what's it be
at some point
at some point some people gotta develop
some situational awareness well abba
here's the problem he's the victim yeah
undoubtedly so but get what you want me
to tell you there's jezebel's out there
there's bad folks
you're not gonna make them stop being
bad
okay
you're doing something terrible stop
they don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care i'm not glorifying it i
don't think it's a good thing that she
did what she did i don't think it's a
good thing for the child either to grow
up with such a vapid succubus like woman
formula i don't think it's probably a
good grade but who knows maybe she might
be a great mother i'm not going to say
for sure but what i am saying is
at some point you have to take
accountability for your lack of
protecting yourself i'm sorry i don't
care how much people say this victory
well if
the genders were reversed i'd say the
same thing
if that man publicized the fact that
he's a boy and you're 19
and you get pregnant by that dude
because you talking with him if you
think i'ma sit up here and tell a grown
woman who's an adult who can vote shoot
do all that good stuff go to jail for
committing crimes if you think i'm gonna
tell her that she should know better
or she should know better and that she's
like needs to be coddled you're crazy i
don't care who it is it's like that dude
that dude okay who it is the guy the
serial cheater the cereal cheater
if now
he gets with another girl and that's the
thing the master cheater i'm not a real
man
if he goes with another girl those
receipts if you get with another girl
and a girl like oh my god well did you
know well yeah i saw the videos but you
know uh
how could he i grew up in the era of
where people would talk [ __ ] about each
other okay and it was just like
gossiping like do you know what he did
let me tell you and this is the kind of
person and i'm like [ __ ] you crazy like
there's videos now
there's literal videos people put them
out of the person's mouth admitting to
what they did and what they want to do
in the future and you [ __ ]
still fall into it and you want to call
bro bro bro bro no no but i gotta ask at
some point it's like it used to be it
used to be he should he said she said
now it's he saw she saw it
he saw she saw he's he saw she saw we
see it
yeah so as far as this update people
want to ask us her thoughts and that's
what i think guys oh jake
oh
she got a tail and some wings and some
horns growing out of her forehead
that [ __ ] is succubus
if i need to tell you to stay away from
that
yeah but that booty though that's really
what happened that's really what
happened i haven't i can't even front
that ass
so she's
hey i can't be mad at her she did what
she did i mean she won
she won she won that's exactly what i
said
but she won
she she said what she was about to do
she called the shot took it she won the
game yeah that's not an update yeah like
how am i gonna be mad at dane lillard
for taking a logo three
no one was guarding him
but he told you what he was going to do
you should have guarded him you know
what i'm saying
he told you look from the from the logo
you'd be like all right then [ __ ] shoot
he drained it right in your face and now
congratulations to brittany renner she
got herself a 20 million contract
she ain't even in the nba imagine
imagine she gonna be clapping her hands
every time this guy's gonna get a new
contract yeah who he signed for what
and you know what yeah you know what's
crazy is like when you join in the nba
they give you a bunch of information
regards to like watching out about your
finances being smarter so they have like
a whole integration process where you
learn about some of the dangers that
pitfalls whether it be family getting
financial advisors all this stuff so
sometimes people just don't want to
listen and if you don't want to listen
how am i going to be mad it's like a
[ __ ] don't pay taxes at 18. like
if the irs comes for you i'm not gonna
feel that sorry for you at some point
you're a grown person you get all the
privileges of being adult that comes
with some responsibilities pay your
taxes pay your thought taxes now too
back in your arm
wow
[Music]
foreign